[Musique]
bonne préparation physique on est parti
sur 5 à 6 semaines prépa physiqueement
l'intégrant football américain puisque
cette année en fait on a un effectif qui
se modifie de de plus en
plus on a un groupe senior pour parler
de l'équipe senior pour l'instant qui
est assez complet étaufé contrairement
aux autres années on a un bon nombre de
joueurs c'està-dire qu'on a entre 40 et
50 licenciers je crois seniors
contrairement à l'année dernière on en
avait une trentaine donc on a fait un
bon
recrutement continue faire réuner le
club avir des performances mais comme on
l'a dit déjà je répète toujours la même
chose comme on l'a dit les autres années
nous on a une autre vision aussi qui
qu'on veut mettre en avant en fait on
veut revenir on veut revenir dans la
ville Descours comme un acteur un acteur
social et un acteur sportif le sportif
on l'a déjà les temp dans course sont
connu et reconnu maintenant acteur
social on va participer à la vie de la
[Musique]
ville